how much do you pay attention to what's
going on in duval with these with these
young rappers you know there's like
well i've been saying that was crazy
they're insane bro like i talked to
young and a's i talked to julio them
guys
if if what they doing if
they was in louisiana like
yeah be [ __ ] up it's a lot of it's a
lot of violence man
yeah but you know that's all come with
it though you know have you
have you talked to either of those kids
like either ace or julio because
he's saying i didn't talk to julio but i
never talked to a man about another man
b
that's really big [ __ ] yeah that's fair
i don't care who i'm with i never talk
to a man about another man beat [ __ ]
if i ain't gonna kill for that man
that's fair you know that's that's
bishop when [ __ ] go around [ __ ] and
say what's that
man you said nah [ __ ] that's your it's
your business that's your business
you know i don't talk to never talk to
ace about fool you'll never talk to
julio about ace
who's talked to ace about getting on a
record right talk to fully about getting
on the rap